[Music]
well george one of the things that
happens in a world gone crazy
is that
people decide they're going to just
change the definitions of things
that's called relativism
and you can just decide
a new definition of a thing by people do
you mean the white house
today it was the white house they
decided they wanted to
to redefine
because they're the white house and they
can do that they get to decide that what
we all thought something was what we've
been taught in every class that we've
ever gone through that something was
that it is not that thing to be fair
john deloney wrote a book called
redefining anxiety see
there it is he redefined it he redefined
it decided but when he finished it was
still anxiety i'll tell you that okay so
so here's a real article from
whitehouse.gov
from the white house website
how do economists determine whether the
economy is in a recession there's the
headline and what does it go on to say
dave this is very interesting
what is a recession
while some maintain that two consecutive
quarters of falling real gdp constitute
a recession
that is neither the official definition
nor the way economists evaluate the
state of the business cycle
uh let me just stop you right there
ball
every econ 101 class
in the united states that was not taught
by the biden administration
has defined a recession
since god was a boy as two consecutive
shrinking quarters of the gdp
ball
okay now let me just make sure i got
that it goes on to say instead both
official determinations of recessions
and economist assessment of economic
activity are based on a holistic look at
the data including labor market consumer
and business spending industrial
production and incomes based on these
data it is unlikely that the decline in
gdp in the first quarter of this year
even if followed by another decline in
the second quarter indicates a recession
if the economy continues to shrink it
must not be a recession because we
decided it wasn't a recession i am
dumber for having read this paragraph
brain cells died while i read this
paragraph how did someone write this in
good conscience and good faith well they
write word salads up there all the time
oh that's right oh my gosh
this is a political word salad yeah
explain why they're doing this because
there's a very clear reason to me well
it's yeah it's classic politics i mean
remember when bill clinton said we had
to define the word is that's right it's
you know it depends on what you're
definitely what you mean by it is is
depends on what you mean by recession
well i actually mean a recession two
consecutive quarters of the gdp
shrinking and that's not a republican or
democrat thing that's just a thing it's
called economics that's just
merriam-webster's opinion dave overdrawn
on your checking account well unless i
decide i don't really want to call it
that i kind of feel like i'm getting
good use of the bank's money yeah was
the money really there holistic approach
to your checking account involves
overdraft fees and
a holistic approach to your uh student
loan is that you keep it your whole
stupid life uh there's a whole i mean
holistic
what are you uh which doctor
holistic economics this is a whole new
way of getting at this there's going to
be a college course about this very
topic oh my god so the real reason is
okay so the real reason the real reason
is politics okay we're going in the
midterm elections and the last thing
that the democrat democratic white house
wants is for the republicans to run
around saying we're in a recession
because we actually freaking are and so
they throw a bunch of democrats out or
the voters throw a bunch of democrats
out office that's all it is they just
don't want to be in a recession going
into these midterms so that's why they
have to change the definition of
recession this is a thousand percent a
pr move uh
political bs yeah that's what it is
okay so yeah depends on what your
definition of
red is
blue
green
i wonder what the definition is
is this a blue shirt oh i know
holistically looking at the shirt it has
some little black lines in it and i
decided it's going to identify as a
black shirt today instead of a blue
shirt so there you go and we're not
going to identify this as a recession
i'm going to self-identify it as
prosperity maybe the white house is
economically colorblind
there we go
that's one that's one reason
there's so many things i can i'm sorry
i'm
if you want to get dumber go read it for
yourself at white house god i feel like
i really have
this is like oh this is like the 70s
were
the 70s were good to the person whose
parents wrote this oh yeah yeah oh my
god they're like their their parents
were had drug use choices were made
while they were doing drugs and that
person wrote this paragraph
oh my god wow lsd was involved i'm just
saying oh my gosh this makes no sense
i don't care i mean listen if trump was
going into a recession
we're going in a recession
if i don't care who puts you there i'm
not even sure we're in one i thought we
were going into one i at least can tell
you that based on the data that will
come out this week yep you should get
the data this week that the second
quarter may not have shrunk
so this may all be for nothing so what
actually i just defended that we get to
redefine these terms to the convenience
of a politician and if we are or are not
in a recession depends on how do you
define
oh you're right i'm sorry you can't
define r until you've defined is
i'm going to walk around with a
dictionary from now on
it's the only way well it's relativism
because you have to do critical thinking
that isn't really thinking there's no
source of truth it's just critical
oh boy you people this is exhausting
yeah so here's the thing
let's just pretend that
when the data comes out this week that
we had two consecutive quarters of the
economy shrinking here's what we do
pretty much know
that it just barely shrunk and if it
didn't shrink it just barely grew
it basically is right around even
which means it's not prosperous but
we're not all going to hell in a
handbasket so it's not going to be a
hurricane tomorrow we're not prospering
it's not a good economy but it's not a
horrible hurricane we're all going to
die recession either we know that even
if it is a recession it's just not that
much of one it's kind of a light rain
not even a good thunderstorm
and so that people are running around
with their helmets on because the
tornado is coming but the um
but yeah no hey here's
so to biden to biden or the democrats
defense
the republicans are going to make a
whole lot more uh
deal out of the recession than it really
is the headlines on their side will make
it feel good
it's joe biden's fault that's what
they're going to do right that's not
true either okay because it's just not
that bad it's not that it's not that
stinky of a recession but it's nothing
to walk around bragging about and it's
nothing to be so concerned about that
you have to redefine terms because we
now know that the democratic party does
not know the definition of is
or the definition of a recession because
they change it at will i just want a
fake book cover of john delony and it
says redefining recessions
just as a spoof just
someone's going to do it now they're
going to bring that back for april so
the deal is
you don't get to re-define a word
to fit your agenda boys and girls well
you can and some of you have pulled it
off
some of you have taken words and they
mean completely other things now because
of your activism and your areas that
you're in but here's one that
well
not gonna work this time one plus one is
two can't change that sorry just
two consecutive quarters of gdp shrink
is a recession
sorry joe not getting by with that word
salad